dans la montagne le long de la route des
cris pour prévenir le danger ce sont des
bûcherons
ils font des vallées le ravin à des
normes rondins de bois
isolé en pleine jungle les hommes de ce
campement de fortune ont pour mission de
fabriquer du charbon de bois
au quotidien ils coupent débite des
dizaines d'arbres
c'est un métier extrêmement difficile
surtout sous la pluie comme aujourd'hui
le chemin devient très glissant mao line
est un ancien huit ans de métier
aujourd'hui il est accompagné de yung fu
élit ses deux neveux
pendant les vacances les enfants
l'accompagnent pour être initiés au
métier de bûcheron
bref vous voyez il faut faire très
attention lorsque le tronc tombe il peut
se casser en deux et vous retomber sur
la tête
alors restez sur vos gardes on voit les
enfants je les fais d'abord commencé sur
les petites branches tu aimes faire sans
nom c'est fatigant c'est vraiment débile
comme métier combien tu gagnes 10 euros
par semaine un métier fatiguant
dangereux mais bien payé ses enfants
gagnent 40 euros par mois soit un quart
du salaire moyen dans la région après la
découpe les enfants charge les fours à
charbon il faut mettre le bois bien au
fond le long des pierres et de l'autre
côté on allume le feu c'est ici que l'on
dépose des braises
ils vont chauffer le bois sous la
chaleur des braises
les bûches vont mettre deux jours à se
transformer en charbon
aujourd'hui ma all-in redescend au
village pour vendre sa marchandise sur
le bord de la route
mais c'est sans compter sur les caprices
de la nature pendant la mousson
il peut pleuvoir jusqu'à huit heures par
jour
il ne faut pas que l'appui dure trop
longtemps sinon on aura du mal à tout
vendre aujourd'hui deux heures plus tard
mao line profite d'une petite accalmie
aller mais correctement ton plastique
s'il te plaît mais pourquoi il pleut et
il faut protéger ton charbon sinon ne
vaudra plus rien vous descendez souvent
au village
ça fait au moins trois allers-retours
entre la route et ici c'est parti des
enfants deux heures de descente sur un
sentier escarpé et glissant avec cinq
kilos de charbon sur le dos pour les
enfants et 15 pour ma all in pourtant
pas question de ralentir
il faut arriver au village rapidement
pour avoir le temps de vendre le charbon
[Musique]
mais impossible de tenir le rythme
au bout de 30 minutes les douleurs dans
le dos sont trop violente
[Musique]
la petite famille est obligée de faire
une pause
[Musique]
ça va
je vais mouiller les pieds
on a du charbon qui nous tombent dans
nos chaussures ça nous laisse les pieds
mais le plus dangereux ce sont les
pierres qui nous tombe sur la tête quand
on longe la falaise
allez on a assez perdu de temps on
repart
[Musique]
c'est en contrebas de ce village que les
attend leur dernière épreuve ils doivent
franchir la rivière pour atteindre la
route
mais pour cela lyon fou est allé
chercher un outil indispensable
ma poule i pour franchir la rivière
c'est à toi
oui on l'a tous la nôtre ici car le seul
moyen de franchir la rivière rapidement
c'est ce câble suspendu dans le vide
il mesure une cinquantaine de mètres et
permet de traverser les rapides en
quelques minutes contre une demi heure
de marche supplémentaire pour atteindre
le premier pont
il y a un an le câble a pris la vie d'un
adulte
depuis aucun enfant ne traverse seul
sans qu'un villageois ne vérifie son
équipement
depuis qu'on a eu l'accident on est
prudent avec les enfants même si les
petits ont l'habitude
à l'époque le câble s'était rompu une
femme avait disparu dans la rivière mais
maintenant nous avons un nouveau câble
si tu tombes tu fais quoi john âge
allez sert bien tes jambes autour du
panier tellement encore un peu
ollo le panier tourner
[Musique]
yung fu a manqué d'élan il se retrouve
suspendue dans le vide au milieu du
câble
c'est leur grande peur à chaque passage
restée bloquée avec une charge trop
lourde à tracter à la seule force des
bras
allez venez m'aider les enfants maryline
vend son charbon sur le bord de la route
un yen le kilo soit un centime d'euro
des risques pour quelques yens
mais il le vendra vite et pourra faire
plusieurs rotations
car le point de vente de mao line se
trouve sur l'axé le plus fréquenté de la
région